[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight for generations california
symbolized everything that was fantastic
was great about America it was the most
beautiful place in the world snow-capped
mountains pristine beaches lush inland
valleys but it was more than a vacation
spot California supported the biggest
middle class in the country
it had a education system the envy of
the world a gleaming infrastructure
California was the state that made the
American dream a reality now the state
of California is known for a very
different set of images needles and
feces in the street a dying middle class
the country's highest poverty rate
policies that prioritize illegal aliens
over ailing American citizens California
is still symbol but today it's a symbol
of everything that's gone wrong with
this country
trace Gallagher joins us tonight with
the latest from the once Golden State
trace and Tucker for governor Gavin
Newsom California is humming along
nicely apparently and he now says the
Republican Party is heading into the
waste bin of history quoting here
America in 2019 is California in the
1990s the xenophobia the nativism the
fear of the other scapegoating talking
down or past people the hysteria and so
we're not going to put up with that
we're going to push back Newsom ended by
saying quote what we're doing is working
I think Democrats are winning right now
apparently somebody forgot to remind the
governor that 40% of his state's
population lives near poverty and then
having among the highest country taxes
in the country and cost of living isn't
exactly giving them a leg up and there's
this July 1st California driver's will
pay six more cents a gallon for gas
taxes that's on top of the twelve cents
last year and on top of already having
the highest gas prices in the country
doesn't appear drivers are winning also
on July 1st California begins background
checks on customers buying bullets the
cost one dollar for every purchase the
check is meant to quickly return
information on restrictions like a
felony conviction and non California
residents can no longer buy ammunition
here period finally a study by homeless
advocates say people on Skid Row have
less access to bathrooms than Syrian
refugees a problem
which is vividly apparent to everyone in
LA in San Francisco but putting in more
mobile bathrooms just in Los Angeles
would cost 57 million dollars a year in
other words it's not going to happen
I've got to believe the homeless don't
feel like they're winning either sucker
what a disaster trace Gallagher thanks a
lot for that well California wages war
on its own middle class and tries to
build men's rooms it cost as much as
houses the governor doesn't see a
problem with the state as you just heard
tens of thousands of middle-class
families have fled and are continuing to
flee every year meanwhile Gavin Newsom
travels to Central America telling his
citizens this priority is helping people
there as a state disintegrates Newsom
says Donald Trump's version of the
Republican Party is what's headed into
the waste bin of history maybe so the
California is going to get there a lot
earlier